computer
okay so it is a thrill and a treat to
have
calvin tsai visiting all the way from
parts unknown from the south pole
antarctica where i spent many a day but
not many as many as calvin he's going to
talk about his adventures in the
southernmost continent antarctica
wintering over
for the bicep
3 experiment and uh paying attention to
all the upgraded technology that's going
down at the south pole for our friendly
competitors by separate and also the
other activities going there and climate
and understanding the properties of
neutrinos
in understanding the uh the atmosphere
all sorts of really cool and interesting
stuff calvin's a delight i had him for
many years as a research assistant in
the lab plus a student one of my best
students of all time
and it's a thrill that we got to have
lunch together and out today
and he's spending some of his time
thawing out
on a well-deserved vacation to southern
san diego and calvin want to take it
away and we'll take questions as they
come up and otherwise we will
uh stand in frigid attention why don't
you take it away
sure thanks brian
uh so um so i spent uh three seasons at
full so that was about 15 months i just
got back last week and i talked about
my experience there and then mostly just
go over pictures and show people what's
going on down there so on this slide
here you see the radomes where we get
our internet signal from satellites
there's three of them for each of the
three satellites that we get internet
from
and you can see some auroras uh in the
sky and then the sun's coming up this is
around sunrise in the background there
so the horizon is kind of bright
and the red lights in the distance back
there is the main station that is about
a mile or so away from the radomes
so we're going to go over some of the
station history um what was what's going
on in the past and then talk about the
current station which is now the
elevator station
talk a little bit about the current
station and then go over bicep overview
and then
uh there will be a bunch of pictures of
and i'll talk about those
so
um
at the south pole uh the first people to
get there were monster scott they raced
uh from the coast to the pole around
1911 1912 starting in december and then
they reached coal in january
uh they used different routes and then
one of the primary differences they also
had and one of the advantages that
munson had was that he used dogs to pull
his sleds and supplies and then scott
used mainly horses and man hauling
a problem here with forces is that they
did not fare very well in the cold uh
their sweat glands and a lot of them
died on the way to antarctica and then
man hauling made things worse because
once they ran out of horses they had to
make fall everything on sleds by
themselves
so that gave scott a huge disadvantage
and also he did not bring enough food
uh and therefore amundsen beat scott by
about 34 days
and then on the way back scott and some
of his men died
on expedition mainly due to starvation
and malnutrition
and then monster had no casualties back
to the coast
and then
so while i was at mcmurdo station which
is one of the staging areas for south
pole
uh i visited
the hut that scott has constructed
on the coast before he made his way to
the pole
uh and one of the mistakes he did while
he was in mcmurdo building this help was
that he bought the hot hut in australia
which was meant to vent heat and keep
things cool so he
uh so
that made things very unpleasant for him
when he was starting off the journey
and then so south station history some
of the things that were here before the
current station
uh so looking at a picture on the bottom
you'll see a monsoon's tent so he
reached uh the pole in 1911
and then nobody really went back there
until the u.s navy set up a more
permanent base
um which was which we call the navy
station and that was through operation
deep freeze where they also set up
mcmurdo
and mcmurdo was used as a staging area
where they would send planes out of
mcmurdo to airdrop supplies buildings uh
food whatever to the people at south
pole and then so the navy ran the south
pole station for close to 20 years or so
until it was handed off to nsf
and nsf built the dome uh because they
needed more
uh more facilities for additional
science and other things that were going
on with the expanding population
and so
after about 30-40 years of the dome
things got pretty buried because snow
just keeps building up
and then eventually it was unfeasible to
keep digging out the dome and then they
built elevator station in 2008 which is
currently still there uh
unless so the dome after it was
decommissioned in 2008 it was
disassembled and the rest of it was
destroyed by dynamite and buried
uh so
if we go to the next slide you can see
uh in the picture here you can see my
pointer the dome is over here this was
before uh blown up by dynamite before
it's buried and this was uh the elevator
station was under construction
uh
in the background here you'll see what
we refer to as the backyard where a lot
of our supplies are left
uh such as additional parts to repair
heavy equipment all the trash is left
over winter to be picked up and driven
out or flown out over summer
over here this is what we call the rod
well it's our well so in order to get
fresh water at pull we
drill down to the ice pump in hot water
that melts the ice and then we pump out
more
cold water that was melted and then so
we don't use all the water that's pumped
out so it's reheated and sent back down
to the hole where it melts more ice and
then so we have a continuous source of
water
so this station called elevator station
supports up to about 200 staff during uh
summer and then during winter uh my
winter there were 39 people who wintered
over usually it's about 40 or 50.
uh and then so we have the smallest
population since 1998
um and then one of the highest
populations was about 80 or so people in
the early 2000s when they were building
the elevator station
um the station is uniquely shaped is the
airfoil shape so the wind usually blows
in this direction
uh towards the backyard and so the
airfoil shape clears out the snow from
underneath the station prevents it from
building up
the problem is now that there's a wall
of snow on this side of the station that
has to be continually bulldozed down and
then driven out
the station is built on stilts and it's
ability to be jacked up
uh
ironically they lost the plans on how to
jack up the station so they don't know
how to jack up the station
um
and they're supposed to jack up the
station within the next year or two
because it's about to get buried
um but and then they're gonna try it out
on some other buildings first before
they jack up the main station
so some uh statistics for 2021 uh when i
winter
uh kevin was the uh
you're saying the main station where we
sleep is gonna be buried
the snow's getting pretty high so
they're doing a lot of work to groom it
but they're going to have to jack it up
soon otherwise it's going to get buried
you mean raise the it's on stilts it's
on jax already but they have to raise it
up is what you're saying that's correct
okay thanks
and so
uh
i mentioned the population and then the
average temperature was negative 78
degrees fahrenheit which was the coldest
average temperature ever at south pole
uh and then the coldest i ever got was
negative 112
fahrenheit and with windchill that
became negative 165.
um and then during the summer
uh temperatures average between zero to
negative 40 fahrenheit
and then so during the winter uh it's
too cold for us to run most of the heavy
equipment
uh you can't run snowmobiles planes
can't fly in so we're isolated during
winter and then during summer they had
to fly all the supplies
um like the food the fuel
all the science equipment we need and
that and they have to prep the station
for the upcoming winter
so at pole along the science sectors
it's called the dark sector uh contains
three buildings uh dsl maple and icl
so dsl is the dark sector lab and hosts
uh southport telescope and bicep three
stability on the left and picture on the
bottom
um so there's bicep three here spt over
here
there's a hallway that links spt to
bicep three and we share the interior
space for computers
and then maple is the building on the
right here it's the martin a pomerantz
uh observatory
um and then bicep array is this big dish
over here there's machine shop on the
first floor so a bicep array shares the
space with the machinist
uh and we have one machinist for uh the
winter
ico is the ice cube lab it is gonna be
off in the distance on the left here not
pictured
but it uh hosts the computer
and um the storage space for ice cube
which is a neutrino observatory
uh
so ice cube
is a special kind of telescope layer
detectors are buried underneath the ice
uh so
uh when they drill uh they bring a big
team um drill about a mile to a mile and
a half underneath the ice and then lay
plant put in
their detectors and then the ice
at pole is especially good for observing
neutrinos so that's why their experiment
is located at pull
and then for the other cnb telescopes
here
um we
are at pole because high altitude uh
cold uh low atmosphere
uh and um the our saint patrick's guy is
always above us so the patch of sky
never goes down that we're observing
and so during winter which is our main
observing season our telescopes are
operating all the time unless we're
cycling in the fridge
so other science sectors at po include
the quiet sector and clean air sector
quiet sector is for monitoring seismic
activity so if you drive a snowmobile or
a tractor or you walk over into the
science sec or into the quiet sector
they will pick it up on their detectors
so it's very sensitive and it's pretty
much closed off unless someone has to go
service uh some equipment out there
and then there's a clean air sector
which is where um a building called
arrow is
hosted
arrow is run by lanoa scientists they do
they monitor the climate and then look
at things such as ozone pollution
things like that
and their
arrow is downwind of a
area where tractors heavy equipment
uh anything that could have uh that
could cause pollution is not allowed to
drive over to keep the air as clean as
possible
and this picture was taken during sunset
right before the sun went down
um so sunset and sunrise that pole
takes a span of two weeks each so the
sky will look like this for about two
weeks before the sun goes all the way
down where it rises all the way up
um so i'm only gonna go and see the
green flash you know
[Music]
um
i didn't see it personally my friend
took a picture of it and i saw it
um so during sunrise my friend and i
were actually the first people to see
the sun come up because it was in the
middle of the night and my friend and i
were up and we saw uh the sun come up
and it was glorious
oh is this a real friend calvin
[Laughter]
i'm sure i wasn't talking myself
okay uh moving on to bicep overview uh
so
bicep does lower science this degree
scale measurements pretty much only
looks at um
cmb to look for primordial b modes
doesn't really do any of the other
science that people like spt or polar
bear or so would be able to do
so they use uh wi-fi refracting
telescopes with uh antenna a couple tes
kilometers
so same ts kilometers as what everybody
else uses in the cmb field
but they use small refracting telescopes
kind of like what so is doing with their
sats
and then
because of this
we're unable to do lensing so
there are plans to work with spt use spt
data for the lensing
and then that's upcoming and future
papers
uh picture on the right is a
time scale of various bicep experiments
from bicep 2 which brian worked on up to
bicep array
and then so
top is the picture of the telescope
middle is what detectors look like and
the bottom is um
a
theoretical picture of what detector
tiles would look like
um so let's start over here on the
bottom left so bicep two used four four
inch wafers
uh cacare expanded on that with five uh
bicep two style receivers uh each with
its own uh focal plane of four four inch
wafers
bicep three uh was larger and it could
accommodate 21 four-inch wafers you can
see a slot is missing here and i know
everybody will ask why there's a slot
missing here
and the answer to that is that with tdm
which is the readout scheme that bicep
uses there was not enough readout to
read out extra detector wafer there so
it was left blank
and so bicep 3 is still observing this
was the telescope i was overseeing
during my winter at pole
and then bicep array deployed in 2019
and then 2020 was his first observing
season and that was the other telescope
i was working with there was another
winter over i worked with who ran by
separate
so with bicep array they moved from four
inch to six inch wafers same focal plane
size but with larger tiles they got rid
of a lot of edges that
the four inch wafers would have had
and the first
bicep array receiver that deployed was
ba1 which was the low frequency receiver
and then there's also uh three keck
receivers and there while the other
bicep receivers are being prepared
so bicep three uh deployed in 2015
observes at one frequency 95 gigahertz
uh
uh at that time
the uh die flexor detectors were not
available yet so it was single frequency
single band
uh has about 2 500 kilometers
and then i made a mistake earlier saying
21 tiles is actually 20 tiles
about 128 kilometers each um and like i
said we're missing a tile because we do
not have the multiplexing
for the additional
tile um and then so the tdm multiplexing
is done with the mcu crates
which is the worm readout mechanic of
tdm and then it is mounted on the same
mount that was used for bicep 1 and
bicep 2 with minor modifications
uh picture on the right there is inside
dark sector lab
the telescope is in the center of the
picture and then my workstation is at
the bottom you can see it's a fairly
small telescope
it pokes its head through uh the ceiling
and then there's a ground shield that i
will show later that protects it from
ground reflections
there's this tiny little monitor on the
right side of
the uh
that is john's little star camera uh
tv that he refuses to let me throw away
it is this horrible little like
um
uh
yeah affordable little black and white
monitor we use for doing star pointing
so bicep doesn't have the resolution to
uh see planets um and that kind of stuff
so we have to have a optical camera to
make our pointy model
all right but for buy separate that's
the start pointing is automated you run
the schedule for doing start pointing
but in bicep three it's all manual you
have to start to start uh
start pointing schedule and then
manually click to let the telescope
track where the star is once it's
centered you move on to the next star
and it's a process it takes about three
hours each time
um and the next thing is i'm going to
talk about is bicep array which is
biceps newer telescope new experiment
it's a completely new mount uh replaced
the daisy's bud and keck mount
and it was designed to hold the larger
weight of
bicep array and this four receivers
first receiver that i was deployed was
ba1 low frequency 30 40 gigahertz um
and then we also used these things
called helium rotary joints which is
what
these things here
uh
lay allow us to move 360 degrees uh in
the asthma stage and our bore side stage
and we don't have to use uh helium cable
wraps
um so
the way it works is that there's a
bottom section here where you can plug
in all your healing lines and the top is
has all these channels and grooves that
isolate the channels from each other and
allow
helium to go into uh the correct fitting
and then you can type it wherever it
needs to go with just
the receivers
uh so
that was the new technology developed by
dsti for bicep array specifically for
helium which was unprecedented because
it's very hard to make something like
this for helium because it is
leaky generally uh
they designed this for us and so far so
good it has performed very well uh much
better than how uh cable wraps would
have performed
um and then
bicep array uh plans to deploy
two 9150 receivers on that a 220 270
receiver
um this year the plan is to deploy one
90 150 uh receiver that's currently a
caltech
um
we were supposed to deploy last year but
due to covet restraints we could not get
the cargo space on a plane going to pull
to deploy a receiver
uh so with fisa beret fully deployed it
would be looking at about 30 000 plus
detectors
we are able to fit this many detectors
because moving up from six inch from the
four inch tiles
gave us more room by neglecting uh the
edges
and then picture on the right the top
picture here is during sunset in 2020
a picture of nathan who was our 2020 uh
winter over those the first observing
season for bicep array after it was
assembled and
it at full
you see there's a big dish surrounding
uh the telescope kind of like
the ground shield for act
uh just prevents ground reflections but
also collects a lot of snow so we have
to shovel it out basically every other
day
uh picture on the bottom
shows cutaways the bicep ray what the
receiver looks like
and what the detectors look like
so
learning from how bicep three was built
uh they improved on bicep ray with a
very similar design so uh with it became
very easy to assemble and disassemble
the receiver uh basically the 300k and
50k shells will lift off
and you are exposed to the focal plane
so the whole process of taking apart
putting together receiver takes about a
day or less
uh so that was the gist of the things i
want to talk about the rest of the
slides are just a picture dump of a
bunch of pictures from my friends
pictures found on the usap website or
pictures i took
um so
i believe this was sunrise uh so this
was the ceremonial poll marker there's
12 flags here each of them representing
a country that signed the antarctic
treaty
so eric treaty
talks about things like no uh weapons
testing no
they don't harm the wildlife no
pollution that kind of stuff so 12
countries signed this treaty and so
these are 12 legs flags represented here
uh the sun is
rising on the right over here that's why
you see the bright spot on the right
and in the tower in the back over there
is the aero tower which is used for
collecting air samples
uh this was taken by my friend around
midwinter which was in uh june
uh so midwinter is basically the most
important holiday for police uh it is
our christmas it is the middle of the
winter and it means that we are halfway
done and we have and we are closer to
getting out of there
uh
so
you can see really nice aurora's this
picture is overexposed um but so
generally they won't look as bright as
that but sometimes they do
the auroras vary in color typically
green purple and red are very common
you get sometimes you get this kind of
aurora which is streaky
they look like lines and they dance
around in the sky and move a lot
uh and then there's another kind which
is
lumpier uh they kind of look like clouds
if you're not paying attention they look
like clouds
um those don't move around them as much
and they don't really change color
um picture here is the geographic pull
marker which is different from the
ceremonial pole marker
uh surveyor comes out every year and
then um because the ice sheet moves at
pole they have to survey where the
actual geographic pole is and shifts
about 30 feet every year
and then
uh the winter overs from the previous
year will design what the poll marker
looks like for next year and that poll
marker would designate the geographic
south pole for the next year
it it is this pole hidden behind the
sign right here
and then so
as the 2020 winter over um we our
station designed uh the geographic south
flow marker that is currently up it was
put up january 1st 2022 and will be up
until
uh january 1st of next year when a new
wine is put in
um and then
you see a bunch of flags and picture um
so
during winter we're not allowed to have
white lights uh on outside because it
affects the aurora cameras some of the
science experiments going on so
we have to use uh red lights uh
headlamps uh and uh
we use the flags to go where we need to
go so there's a flag line going out to
dsl if it did not exist i would probably
have gone lost several times
um so flags are super helpful they let
you know where you go when um it's super
dark for six months
this is another picture my friend took
more aurora's
there's the station down there
you can see the milky way in the
background
probably notice that
the ground is very flat uh and you can
see pretty far um that is how it is at
pole it is basically a plateau of ice
that is two miles thick
and there's no features there are no
mountains uh no canyons nothing but flat
for miles and miles miles
uh
there's main station here
this
is where our galley would be so this
would be where we eat our meals
and then
offices and the main station science lab
is in this section of uh the station
and then this is what we call a beer can
because it looks like a beer can uh
you go down
several stories and you would enter
where our power plant is
where vehicle maintenance facility is
and where a lot of our supplies like
fuel and food are stored so things are
stored underground uh just because it's
colder down there and temperatures are
more stable than if we put them outside
this picture i took of biceps three um
during sunrise um so
at about a day or two after sunrise i
went out to dark sector lab and took
this picture
uh you can see uh this is the ground
chia for bicep three uh similar to bicep
arrays but smaller
biceps 3 is inside there there is a
hatch over here that
i can open to go inside to do all the
work i need to
uh list is
the first plane landing at pole uh after
winter first plane arrived
i think mid september it was on
a deployment flight on the way to
mcmurdo from a british station on the
coast
uh this type of plane is called a
basilar it is a modified dc3 uh
company that operates these planes in
archives called camboric air or kba for
short
they are
the primary
company for operating flights in and out
of pole besides the us air guard
so kba flies these basilars they're
mainly used for passenger transport
they're not really big enough for cargo
and then the air guard runs um c-130s
and lc-130s and these are big cargo
planes with skis and um they can land at
pole because there's skis we don't have
an actual runway so any plane that lands
here has to land on skis
and during winter it's too cold for most
plants to land um so anything with
hydraulics it's not able to land during
winter so if there was a medevac during
winter they have to bring in a plane
called the twin otter which
is really little and
pretty old doesn't have any hydraulics
so it's able to land during winter
so even a plane like this master won't
be able to land during winter
uh so
the first summer i was there uh in 2020
uh there was covid and they were
paranoid that uh bringing a lot of
flights into station would cause covet
to have an outbreak so they limited
flights to only these basilars and then
everything else was driven in by tractor
uh it takes about two weeks or more for
people to drive from mcmurdo to pole to
deliver fuel and food
and land it's about about another two
weeks to get back to mcmurdo
uh during this past summer 2021 we were
able to bring in
a few lc-130s and
that resupply station with food fuel and
then some of the size cargo we need to
calibrate bicycle ray
uh the flags here are for visibility
reasons the meteorologist from station
uses leaves to gauge the weather and
then the pilots also use lease to gauge
how much runway they have left when
they're running when they're landing
and then the meteorologist also does
weather balloon launches about once or
twice a day
more if a plane is landing
so
um those was at sunrise so it's a
weather balloon um
they these are not recoverable for the
most part they launch it they get the
data balloon pops it falls back down to
uh to earth and then that's the end of
that
sometimes a lot they'll launch
instruments that have to be recovered
and then they'll go on a snowmobile and
usually the balloon is about a mile or
two away from station to recover
this was uh the
eclipse in december
so this is a bunch of images stacked on
top of each other
uh my friends took this um
it made its way around the internet so
some of you might have seen this
but we got a 90 totality eclipse
at po in december uh this past year
and so
we could see the temperature dropped it
got dark at pole
you can see how
the sun is almost totally eclipsed here
by the moon and then there's spt down
there you can see bicep three
um
yeah it's a cool picture like a lot
and then picture credits uh
so jeff keller he was one of the control
engineers on nathan precup he was a ba
winter over
past year among was this current year's
pt winner over and got some pictures
from the bicep cut collaboration and
also from usap uh ucep stands for united
states antarctic program
so thanks for listening my talk
this is a picture of this past summer's
uh
bicep crew where we had to service the
bicep raid telescope
awesome
great
uh so i have some questions but uh let
me open it to other people first
any questions this unmute
um what's it like you know the physical
tests psychological tests
etc
uh to get to the poll how competitive is
it and what hoops do you have to jump
through
uh so for the medical exam it's a full
physical check they want to make sure
you don't have any issues that will come
up and with kovid
they put an age requirement and got
stricter on
being overweight and high blood pressure
and things like that
uh so
that disqualified a lot of
the veterans from coming back that have
been coming for years because some of
them were getting old and we're allowed
back because of the new code
restrictions
um you also have to get a dental exam
and then blood tests done and get a
bunch of other vaccinations
uh
just so
you don't bring in some kind of disease
make sure you don't have any blood
issues
make sure you won't have
any dental problems
they also brought a dentist right before
winter just to check everybody's teeth
and give everybody a clean up
before winter started
and then over winter there's one doctor
and one pa on station
and so there's a problem at least
there's somebody there that can help you
uh for a psychological test they got rid
of that a few years ago and it got
replaced it with team building events
um so we did team building over zoom
because usually they would meet at ss
park on a new team building there
but with covet
in 2020 we weren't allowed to meet and
ask to spark so it was all over soon
okay uh
hey brian sean casey i have a question
sure
uh calvin uh for the bicep experiment
what is the typical observing efficiency
down at the pole you know if you take
the time that's available and how much
of that actually gets converted into
science time
for the cmb experiments down there
yeah so uh during summer is when we
service our telescopes because we can
bring in science equipment bringing
calibration equipment so
uh this past summer
uh bicep array and biceps three were
calibrating and so we didn't do any
science observations but uh during
winter uh bicep 3 and bicep beret are
observing full time
uh we're only stopping observations if
there's a problem
and so for biceps 3 we run on a 72-hour
schedule where we observe for 66 hours
and then cycle the fridge for six hours
and that's continuous so every
72 hours there is a six hour downtime
cycle of fridge and that's it and that's
the time we use to go into the mound go
to the ground shield clean out the snow
service while we need a service um and
then once those six hours up the
telescope starts observing again
uh for bicep array it's a little
different
bicep array has the capability to do a
72-hour hold time but we're limited by
the tech receivers which are older and
only have a 48-hour whole time so
uh same thing minus a day for a bicep
array
and then you're observing uh as soon as
the poll shuts down
or how does that work what's the
observing schedule i mean
is it officially at winter or
you know if you look at 365 days
out of the year
yeah so
winter is technically starts um
as soon as uh it gets too cold and last
plane leaves and summer begins when the
first plane arrives so typically last
plane leaves mid-february so a poll
right now the last plane is about to
leave uh and
we got our first plane in after winter
about mid-september
and so we're observing all the time
unless we're calibrating or unless
there's downtime to fix the telescope
so
the summer before this one
we were observing the whole time because
we weren't calibrating
the instrument during summer but during
summer the data isn't very good because
sky temperature fluctuates because the
sun is up so
we don't typically
um make it a point to observe during
summer we use that time to service the
telescope because winter data is much
better and the sky temperature is much
more stable
okay hey thank you collin
great talk too thank you
thank you that's from a former poll
inhabitant himself sean k dr sean casey
uh any other um questions for
calvin or comments
if not
i'll go ahead yeah
uh yeah i've got two uh first have you
ever seen the thing uh
yeah
there's a tradition at pole where we
watch all three of the thing movies as
soon as the uh first uh last plane
leaves in february
that's that's awesome um and then i
guess the other question was
uh how how far can you guys like explore
on the site like i assume there's like a
safe area like perimeter that you they
don't want you to go past because it's
dangerous to go walking outside of that
i'm just curious how far you can go
yeah uh
about two miles is what they tell us
within radio range is uh what they want
us to be in uh there's attenuator for
our radio system so that the signal
doesn't contaminate the cmb telescopes
there on there's a point on station
called end of the world which is the end
of the backyard so let me go back a few
slides
uh so end of the world is about this
marker over here and that is the end of
the backyard and there is a hut there
you can sign your name if you make it to
the end of the world and that is
theoretically as far as you really
should be going
cool thank you so much
sure
all right
okay
thank you calvin that's been awesome
i'm gonna stop the recording here